- [Mark] All right, David.
David, where are you from
originally? Where'd you grow up?
- [David] Reserve, New Mexico.
- [Mark] New Mexico?
- [David] Yes.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You grew up with both of your parents?
- I grew up with adopted parents
and I lived in a small village
in the middle of the forest.
Everything is far away.
But as I grew up,
I had a very, very troubled experience.
- [Mark] What happened?
- When I was little, my
parents used to neglect me
and leave me inside the room with nothing
and I didn't eat at all.
I used to drink piss out
the bottle to survive.
My dad hit me with a board,
like that, metal on the back.
I started getting in and out
of jail at the age of 13,
all the way to the age of 17,
because I couldn't
really deal with the pain
and the abuse that I was
going through with my parents.
When I was 17 then I
started striving to look
for my adopted, or my biological mother.
When I found her, I was with her a week,
caught her doing heroin in the room
and she kicked me out in the streets
and I've been homeless for seven months.
When I was a little kid, it was hard,
especially for me because I
grew up out in the country,
I didn't grow up in the city.
But you know, I started trying
to change my life around.
I still have the memories,
but I try to move on.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- 18.
- [Mark] You're 18?
- Yeah, 18 and a half.
I've been on the streets for seven months.
- [Mark] So you were staying
with your mom recently?
Your real, biological mom?
- I got off a year's probation,
I stayed with my grandmother in Oklahoma
and I caught a Greyhound out
from Oklahoma to New Mexico
because I'd moved from New Mexico to there
when I got out of jail.
I was with my mother for one week.
Ever since then, I've been homeless.
So I hitchhiked.
I hitchhiked all the way
from Reserve, Mexico to here.
But when I went back out to Oklahoma
after my mother had
kicked me out, I, you know
went back to Oklahoma
and my grandmother was, you
know, trying to explain to me,
like, I know you've had a
troubled past and stuff like that,
but move on.
So of course I came out here
to Los Angeles for the dream,
but I still go every day.
- [Mark] To where?
- Just trying to hang in there.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
Are you using any of the
drugs that are out here?
- Recently, I'm not gonna lie, yes.
I've done drugs quite a bit,
but I'm trying to mellow
myself away from it.
- [Mark] What drugs have you used?
- Popped xannies.
Used to pop like, three of them at a time.
I smoke weed because it helps me out.
Yeah, I'm kind of a drinker, but...
And I try to stay away from
meth and heroin, if anything,
but yeah, I have done meth
and overdone it, that's why.
- [Mark] What are you doing for money now?
- [David] Right now I'm
pretty much stranded
at a point where I can't make anything.
I've went around to places around here.
Here's two things, either
I go back to my home state
or I stay here and try to make a living
out here in California.
I don't want to end up like,
to the point where I'm dirty 24/7,
so I try to keep myself clean as possible.
I get any showers I can
take, any clothes I can get.
I do what I can do.
- [Mark] Where do you sleep now?
- [David] I sleep anywhere
I can find that's clean.
Not shit and pissed on--
- [Mark] You don't have a tent?
- [David] I don't have a tent.
I don't have any equipment.
The only stuff I have is this right here.
- [Mark] Your backpack?
- [David] Yup.
- [Mark] It's a big backpack.
- [David] Yup, I had 260
pounds in that before.
- [Mark] Wow.
So your relationship with your
foster parents is not great?
- [David] It never really was great.
It was one day, they're cool,
the next day they're pissed off.
And my mother, when my
mother got pissed off,
she used to throw knives
over the counter top at me.
- [Mark] And they were doing drugs or--
- No, my dad worked in Freeport McMoRan
in Morenci for 21 years.
He'd come home from work, beat
the shit out of me, and then,
yeah.
- [Mark] So your relationship
with your biological mom
is no better, right?
- Well, my biological mom,
I haven't gotten to know her that well,
she kicked me out after
one week of knowing her.
My adopted mother is now
trying to convince me
of all kinds of stuff, and, you know,
it's kind of hard to trust her
after the stuff that I
went through for years,
since the age of six.
- [Mark] did you finish high school?
- No, I was pulled out at
ninth grade by my parents.
There was a lawsuit against the school
because my dad was trying
to make millions off of
suing the school.
He was using me as an advantage.
- [Mark] So do you have an ID at least?
- I don't have an ID,
don't have social security,
all that's been stolen.
That's why I went around
with all my stuff,
I try to keep an eye on it.
Because out here people's
already jacked stuff from me.
- [Mark] That happens everyday here.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have siblings or anything?
- I got a few left, but I
don't see them that much.
I got one friend that I call
a true friend just because
he helped me out recently
when I was in New Mexico.
But you know, I've hitchhiked
7,000 miles this year, total.
Or 2019 anyways.
You know, I'm young, but I've
gotten to the point where,
you know, I did a lot of
drugs and alcohol in my teens,
when I was a minor.
Now that I'm getting older, it just
feels like it's getting too old,
like I don't really want to, you know
mess with that stuff anymore.
So I've been trying to keep
myself a little bit sober
off of a lot of it, just smoke weed.
The reason why I smoke weed
'cause I have serious PTSD.
My PTSD
flashbacks will come
in when I see something
that reminds me of something
that happened to me.
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff happened to you
in your childhood that
was the most traumatic?
- The most traumatic was
when I was little, my mother,
when I was taking a bath, she would
chase me around the house naked and then
beat the shit out of me.
She used to call my dad and
tell him all kinds of stuff
and he would come home and...
It was hell with him.
It was a lot more complicated
than most families.
When you talk abuse,
my dad used his fists.
I got so used to it,
I'm not scared of dying,
I'm not scared of fighting anymore.
So I'm hoping that I could get my GED
and just kind of get a job.
You know what I mean?
I've been broke, I've been
broke for a long time.
- [Mark] That would be a great plan.
So, you know, I appreciate
you wanting to hear something,
but you know, everything
I'm telling you is the truth
because the stuff that
I went through is bad.
And there's some stuff that I
don't want to say on camera,
if you know what I mean.
And I'll kind of give
whoever's watching this a hint
about how bad it was.
And yes, I have been bull whipped.
I've been bull whipped.
That is one of the most
painfullest, painfullest
thing that can happen to you.
- [Mark] This is about
your adopted parents?
- My adopted father used to
take a bullwhip, (hisses)
go around me like that,
it wrapped around me
and slapped me in the chest really hard.
It was so painful I felt
like I was about to just...
These days when I wreck
or if I break my arm
or whatever I do, I broke my
wrist about two months ago,
I kinda like, tolerate the
pain because I'm so used to it.
- [Mark] Well good luck with everything,
and try to steer clear of all the drugs.
- Yes, sir.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.